tonight we're about 15 weeks out from
the 2020 election if you can believe it
and
the last few days have revealed the
candidates starkly different approaches
to leadership
now each one has tried to improve his
standing on the economy and or covet now
when biden though emerges from his comfy
basement
he often is just shuffling upstairs to a
camera near his
french doors with a bucolic scene
framing the shot
yesterday he tried to show us that he'd
be more hands-on
regarding the pandemic offering
never-before-heard solutions like
appoint a commanding covet officer or
he'd help small businesses oh wait
didn't trump already do that try again
joe
well of course we know regardless of
what he says the only big thing that
poor old joe would do differently
are the lockdowns in other words he'd
mandate a national
shelter in place order which of course
would push us toward a socialist cliff
and over time it would end up killing
more people than it would save
but of course he had to start his
attempt at relevancy
with a shot at the trump economy this
man simply doesn't understand
he can't deal with our economic crisis
without serving and saving and solving
the public health crisis for all his
bluster
about his expertise on the economy he's
unable to explain
how it'll actually help working families
hit the hardest
i mean just laughable trump's retort to
this is so easy
he kept the economy afloat by signing an
unprecedented relief package
and his resistance to permanent
lockdowns
actually helped the economy rebound
faster than
any of the so-called experts could ever
have imagined
want to go back to work as opposed to be
sort of forced into a position where
they're making more money than
they expected to make and the employers
are having a hard time getting them back
to work
we were very generous with them i think
that uh
it's been a tremendously successful
program we're in a pandemic
and yet we're producing tremendous
number of jobs that was something that
nobody thought possible
well he's right about them beyond the
generous checks and to american workers
more generous than i might have liked
but we are already seeing a recovery 4.8
million jobs added in june
after 2.7 million added in may so
could a biden economy ever approach that
in the middle of a pandemic of course
not
because with no credible plan to create
jobs biden could only use the
empathizer in chief approach while trash
talking
school reopening plans if you had to put
your
career on hold indefinitely or senior
hours cut or your job lost
the confusion the confusion over school
reopening only makes things worse
the confusion over school reopenings the
president
has been incredibly consistent on this
i think they should open the schools
absolutely i don't consider our country
coming back if the schools are closed
open up our schools open them up data
shows children have the lowest fatality
risk
your son your grandchildren are you
comfortable do you plan to
have them back in person in school yeah
i am comfortable with that but
joe biden's points on this are all union
talking points basically
biden wants to unionize child care and
home health care workers
he wants to give the teachers unions a
big basically at stay-at-home vacation
keep all the kids at home and with the
health care workers and the other
workers getting unionized who gets to
foot that bill the way we pay for it is
by rolling back unproductive tax cuts
while ensuring high income earners
pay their tax bills we invest that that
would add up to 775
billion dollars over 10 years oh that's
a lot of unproductive tax cuts isn't it
and of course by investment joe biden
means spending
well there's no such thing as a free
lunch or free elder care
or free child care as nice as that
sounds
you'll be built for the cash with
crushing new taxes
while he and his cronies create a new
government-funded series of unions
all captive to the democrat party but
don't worry about all the details
after all joe doesn't have to because
the press is essentially acting
as his campaign coms team now while the
president himself he faces these types
of inquiries
do you plan to do a national strategy to
help schools
reopen and reopen safely do you want the
american people to judge you
on the ballot in november by how do you
handle this pandemic
three governors today came out with new
orders on mass requirements is that
something you wish
all the governors would do if americans
keep dying
are you responsible for that okay
nice people by contrast this was biden's
q a session yesterday
thank you for listening i look forward
to having your questions at another time
but i'm off to another event
thank you
[Applause]
i mean they don't even bother shouting
questions anymore he just shuffles off
daughters off the stage bye joe
now time and again he devolves into
bromides biden does
with all the originality of a hallmark
card
president's supposed to care to lead
to take responsibility to never give up
that's what presidents are supposed to
do
it's like one of those corporate posters
while empathy is nice
don't be fooled by the aw shuck stuff
that he's selling
this is all part of a carefully
orchestrated masquerade
look at joe he's such a sweet old man
and he really
cares about us this is uh joe biden's
empathy which uh people believe is a
real selling point we know
biden has empathy but this time around
he connected
policy and empathy he understands that
empathy isn't a huge part of this job
will you come back
i'll be happy to come back by the way we
were thinking to you as vice president
but then you took this job
so you know what what can we do
you know he wanted to just lean in for
that shoulder rub but
he got confused he was on satellite now
this is the kindly face of an
administration
that's going to ram through crushing
regulations speech codes
new taxes reparations and radicalism at
every turn
meanwhile biden refuses to subject
himself to difficult interviews
either because he's incapable of
answering tough questions
cognitive decline or he's afraid that
maybe he'll reveal the truth
that to survive in his party he's become
little more than a puppet
of the radical left in blm it's a
movement that believes the founders were
evil
capitalism is evil the constitution is
evil
most americans are racist and thus evil
you get my drift but we're supposed to
believe that the only guy
is sweet old joe biden who can save us
are we supposed to believe now that
obama you know he
he wasn't as talented as joe is now i
mean they were together for eight years
well so barack obama wasn't really
authentic couldn't get the job done
the most telling moment over the last
few days was when biden invoked his dad
he used to have a saying he said joey i
don't expect the government
to solve my problems but i sure in hell
expect them to understand my problem
well that's complete nonsense the
government's job is to allow you the
freedom
to solve your own problems and make your
own way
government doesn't understand anything
it's not a person
we have to see the gauzy biden sympathy
routine for what it is
just because someone claims to care
doesn't mean they can make our lives
better or strengthen our nation
jimmy carter cared look where that got
us
time and again we see biden wear
compassion
as fashion but the you know
i care stuff is just a veneer to
distract from how far
left that he's had to move on almost
every major
issue facing america and he's even
trying to perfect the squad's racial
smears
no sitting president has ever done this
never
never never no republican president has
done this no democratic president
we've have racist and they've existed
they've tried to get elected president
he's the first one that has
number one that's disgusting number two
it's false and defamatory
trump shouldn't tolerate this and he
should continue to appeal the black
voters about the outright lies they're
being told
in order to hold them back and number
three
it's all very ironic given biden's
own checkered history on racial rhetoric
and his abysmal policy failures
president trump slapped back today we
passed criminal justice reform something
that obama
and biden were unable to do we did
opportunity cities we had the best
african-american hispanic-american
asian-american almost every group was
the best for
unemployment that's what i call caring
results and you know what real
compassion looks like
offering crime-fighting assistance to
the most crime-ravaged communities in
america
where law-abiding americans many of them
black suffered due to unprosecuted drug
and gang violence today i'm announcing a
surge of federal law enforcement into
american
communities plagued by violent crime
operational legend
is not to harass it's not to harm or to
hurt
it is to help investigate unsolved
murders
in which one of those happened to be our
innocent four-year-old son
we have to take a stand in our
communities and speak up to help this
operation
everyone should watch that operation
legend event today
i'll tweet it out later you'll be better
for watching it
biden is engaged in a high-stakes shell
game
stoke enough fear in the public about
the virus or racism
and maybe no one will notice that he's a
doddering fool who can't control the mob
on the streets
or the mob in his own party this is one
care package that will blow up our
future if we let it
and that's the angle